what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation greg here today thank you for clicking
on this video so we are going to talk about some
dc news that's been heavily reported to be coming
out of comic-con tomorrow i'm going to be having
a marvel video going up on the channel i asked on
our community page and twitter what are you most
hoping comes out of comic con so i'm going to be
reacting to and riffing off of those responses
but right now i want to talk about this which
kind of threw me for a loop because earlier
this week you might have heard there was this
rolling stones article that came out about the
wb claims involving a bot infested snyder cut
movement that was basically saying 13 of hashtag
released the snyder cut movement accounts were
bots takeaway that seemed pretty obvious that
they wanted the readers to have was wb they got
duped they got duped by a bunch of you know this
vocal minority that was just so passionate that
created all these bots and then they wasted all
this money now i'm probably gonna circle back
to that in a minute but this is the video is not
mainly about that but the reason i'm bringing it
up is because of what's being reported on right
now is something that i very much do associate
with you know the snyder verse when i woke up i
saw this all over my twitter feed it's been up
for a few hours now henry cavill's superman return
is rumored for an official announcement by henry
cavill at hall h this weekend and honestly
i'll tell you guys when i first read that
the way it was presented my heart
stopped for a couple of beats
i know that sounds like silly and dramatic
i just was like wow wait is this actually
happening there's a level with you unlike superman
i actually lost hope that this would ever happen
so diving into it more websites i mainly been
pulling from this deadline article and deadline is
obviously one of the more reliable entertainment
news outlets the article goes on to say dwayne
johnson in the warner brothers theatrical session
will serve as marvel's opening act earlier in the
day with black adam and shazam fury of the gods
getting their much-deserved close-ups on the hall
h stage there's also a buzz that henry cavill put
in a surprise appearance to talk up more superman
there's just been so many conflicting reports
about henry cavill's superman future for years
now many have stated he's gone others have stated
he's in negotiations for like a future cameos
reportedly the new people in charge of warner
media are like no we need to revitalize superman
regardless even if you take henry cavill out of
the equation it's very obvious that they just
haven't had a clear confident direction of what
to do with superman the last two appearances if
i'm not mistaken other than you know zack snyder's
justice league which is meant to predate these is
shazam and peacemaker with which both featured
faceless voiceless cameos by the man of steel
it's just kind of crazy to know that even with
his time as superman he did have a you know
a complete character arc from man of steel
to zack snyder's justice league he's only had
one solo outing as superman now one thing
that's really kind of kept hope alive
is online teases that dwayne johnson and henry
cavill have given about them mashing up together
because dwayne johnson he's been very outspoken
about wanting black adam to fight superman i mean
dwayne the rock johnson he obviously holds a lot
of power and influence and is also very much about
staying connected to what the fans want although
i'm sure if he fought superman he'd probably make
sure that superman lost her that'd be a draw or
some [__] like that so if this report is true
i'm totally cool with there being more cameo
appearances as a way to you know get him back
into the freaking dc films god damn i really think
he deserves another solo movie fans have wanted
another man of steel follow-up for so long and
like i said earlier i really appreciated his arc
through the three films that he was in even though
zack snyder had a plan for two more justice league
films i still feel like the way that film ended
whether you go off of the joss whedon version or
the zack snyder's justice league version you can
still do another solo outing another official
sequel to man of steel and my god i hope that if
they were to do that that it would be following
after the events attack centers justice league
another job sweden despite whichever one they
would want to make it a sequel out of you can
still just make it your own and just factor in
the events of the prior installments they could
do it in a way where it's like oh it could be
followed after either one of those depending on
how you interpret it now for me the real question
is if there was to be another solo outing would
zack snyder return to direct it that just seems
very unlikely because of the major contention
that's very public between zack snyder and wb
it's not impossible it's not possible but that is
one that make me go wow holy [__] they squashed
some real beefs there but i'll be honest you know
i could see another director doing it but whoever
they would get for it i i think they would have to
be able to match or level up from the man of steel
action out of the zack snyder trilogy the man of
steel action is still the best superman action
has ever been and i'll be damned if we get another
solo movie and the action is nowhere near on that
level they don't have to like destroy cities and
[__] but you know like the choreography and like
the fighting style it was just so great although
i am curious from snyder fans would you be cool
with henry returning for a solo movie without
zack stein it's a big part of what i feel like
ignited the snyder cut movement was more than
just i want to see a better film was being aware
of the treatment and handling of zack snyder while
dealing with a personal tragedy so getting a bad
film compounded with that usually ignites a
passion like nothing ignites a passion more
than feeling like something's been wronged and we
gotta fight for justice all puns intended because
a lot of that rolling stone article like i get
it there's obviously a lot of passionate fans
out there who can be very difficult to deal with
who can be very hostile and insulting to others
every fandom has this level of aggressiveness
and bullying and there's many who believe that
the snyder cut fan base had the worst of them i
understand but when we're talking about this bot
situation you know i'm going back to like the if
we look back at the launch of hbo max one of the
main things to truly entice people to sign up very
early on was green lighting zack snyder's justice
league you know while 13 of the accounts are fake
87 percent is very real you're still telling me 87
is very real and that 80 that's a lot of
people i don't know the exact number but
it's it's got to be a lot and regardless
it's also saying the movement is mainly
real people this whole narrative about we
got duped and bullied into releasing this
by a small amount of loud angry fans to me
it just didn't register as the data doesn't
support this that 87 percent of people can be
a lot of people like think of it like this this
might be a terrible example but let me let me
try to think of it if i go and rhyme tomatoes
and i see a movie has a 70 score and then i see
another movie that has a 90 score it's easy to
look at that and go one movie is definitely better
if i see that 70 score movie has like 350 reviews
and the 90 score movie has like 20 reviews it kind
of changes up the variables you know like how many
people make up that 87 percent i i definitely
could use a better analogy than the right
tomatoes we just talked about for so many years
and as one of the channels i was also covering it
i don't know it seemed very real to me and the
last time we saw henry cavill superman was in
that film and his superman is very much associated
with the snyder verse so to me it'd just be kind
of crazy in the week of wb again trying to take
down snyder that this announcement would happen
even without zack snyder's theory in the future of
superman now i know that marvel has a reputation
for being you know other than the leaks for being
very successful at keeping their announcements
for comic-con very secretive i don't know if
warner brothers is as good about it and you
know i i definitely do believe that henry cavill
can't continue on without zack snyder directing
regardless that's just my two cents on this uh
i'm hoping that this really does get announced
that would be very exciting and i'll just quickly
say despite it being several years since henry
cavill played the man of steel obviously he
can still pull off superman he can still pull
it off yeah leave me your thoughts down below
thank you guys for being here you can subscribe
click that bell keep a lookout for whatever
we come cover at comic-con catch you guys soon